rocket League is getting even more DLC  this week and this time it will be  portal themed rocket League developer  psyonix announced a partnership with  valve which is bringing a bunch of new  portal items to the game on PC for free  starting December 1 the items include a  chopper in the form of cake three new  rocket trails which you can choose to be  conversion propulsion or repulsion gel  respectively and a number of antennas  including a companion cube personality  core picks to go for potatoes GLaDOS is  more petite every form the items will be  randomly awarded after completion of a  full match win or lose sadly there are  no actual portals being added to spice  up the gameplay also arriving corocut  leaked in December is the Mad Max test  chaos run and Winter Games DLC packs let  me know what game themed stuff you want  to see in rocket league next and stay  tuned to game spot for all the latest